welcome to the recruitment rollercoaster
podcast my name is Hisham azuz and today
I'm in Manchester and with Jake Whitby
who's a senior consultant at Oak well
Hampton some in their offices recording
the podcast today and look great to
finally meet you mate
yeah LinkedIn and stuff at me so yes and
as you know we're always like to start
how did Jake from Manchester into the
word recruitment mate shows me yeah well
thanks very much for coming down
well so it all started I guess after uni
didn't really know what was happening
and then finished uni would you do it
Union I did international business okay
so always like business technology and
then it was like oh hey like this big
world of sales is there mmm so spend a
couple of months getting a job and then
I was doing subspace sales already and I
got it straight into that yeah yeah I
could tell him attics company darling
ready to move down there oh really
that was sick really yeah I was like 21
flying all over the world like selling
software I mean clients that was pretty
sweet
like I remember flames like la in the
first week of work really like the Neo
thank you employee orientation so anyway
did that for a year wait to come back to
Manchester reading was a bit of a shell
to be honest so came back to Manchester
did some interviews and then a joined
erm I've always thought about being a
financial adviser so I kind of did this
so many views there then I got a job at
a company called think money okay and
and then I got an interview and a job at
a company called net source small little
about 20 man recruitment company run by
a guy called Nick Paul nice company and
it was it was more it was an old older
workforce that's saying the kind of I
was like young 21 in the light you know
34 he worked for us really nice people
they had some big accounts that they
were working and stayed there about four
or five bumps and just for you know I
wanted so you went into real criminal
yeah yeah yeah yeah so stayed there for
four or five months four there's just
more it was literally because they
wanted to utilize
my sales experience first day there's a
computer going to in order to go and
open up some accounts so obviously we
love it yeah because of my sales
experience it was very much like yeah
fine I'll get on the phone
smash the phone yeah and it was just
more ya must have something up really
yeah what was your perception of
recruitment at that point had you'd like
dealt with recruiters dealt with
recruiters yeah it's a guy a guy called
Dale whatever from this is prime mu now
was his own little graduate recruitment
company he started this year seems to be
doing really well and I'm looking back
he just used like all the tactic yeah
all on that Rolex me looking back I was
just like ah he made me sort like a
chump I over there well obviously it got
means the world of recruitment yeah okay
so how long have you been in recruitment
it's a bow I'm calling not to kind of
like four and a half years now I think
five years yeah yet getting there yeah
so okay well I always like to touch them
before you would talk about how where
you went after that first yeah
experience but how tough was that then
like so obviously it made sense that
they'd try neutralize your sales
experience get this lad and Jake he can
do sales to get making those a bid
equals I think it was that grim I think
it was it wasn't too grim okay so you'd
be honest I think because of my from
doing sales and just smashing the
phone's 9:00 to 5:00 but finished
wake-up call was like on the first day I
was like rocking at nine and a half a
and I was like whoa I'm working till six
as well it was it wasn't grim it was
just like it wasn't until I went to my
next place that I really yeah and I
think because I did a couple of place
and it about like 20 grand in my I think
five or six months which it's not set in
the world on fire but not we've like no
real training and just Todd's like go on
and do with it kind of get on and yeah
that literally was the crack yeah but
the ad like they were nice nice people
to you know keeping contact with Nick
quite a bit the old MD okay so then
after that after that you then joined
energize okay and then he was there for
I was there for I think around three
years I think three years yeah and then
and came back yep
which we'll get onto and then you join
oak well yeah join Oakland and then you
know now been here nearly a year yeah
yeah
okay calm it so and alright so clearly
had the biggest in energized yeah and
was you always doing what you use wooden
perm you said yeah pen for the for three
years three years okay and then was it
the same mark that you ended up in when
you're doing the BD row or was it a
different market how do you mean the
sector so yeah I did net Birmingham okay
that was my little baby thought Annette
Berman yeah yeah I was do Microsoft
development behaving game really yeah
yeah says in like you wasn't in
Birmingham no now isn't mine Chester in
the offices went down there you know
meet some clients Romans all right I
went there for the first time like the
other weeks little business it's not
much faster you love monkeys didn't know
okay let's break down that that free up
here so like obviously what I'd loved
what I'm looking forward to getting into
is um obviously during that time and
enjoyed we went to America right yeah
how many years was that and that was
like 18 months in okay well okay so like
one and a half yeah one of our fears
doing done it been getting 1/2 years do
in America okay yeah sweet so yeah
looking forward to dive into that but I
guess before we get into this sort of
American and journey like obviously that
was your your solidest in so I guess
what went on energized in the first time
on sand is that where you really sort of
earned your stripes and yes yeah so wet
now the reason why I went anodized
because of the training well I went from
a place it didn't really have anything
and a way to be a recruit I kind of form
up saying I like that I like it I want
it to really kind of hone my skills and
then something they did there you know
for the first first kind of couple of
months go through some good training won
some awards for it which is decent and
then cracking um but it wasn't easy you
know didn't bill for like four or five
months and what after the training well
yeah that's some time like obviously I
did bill for four or five months
first one for the building for deals in
the first moments yeah okay that's
interesting there so I guess just a
quick one on that because I think that's
a really interesting point because a lot
of people end up in recruitment fall
into it as you hear all the time and
then they'd obviously add shots and
deepen our difficult chats in the deep
end yes and but again I joined a small
business so I mean I did get put on some
like a training course but it was all
right wasn't right so I guess how how
looking back how do you think that
training like where do you think it
helped you the most you can said you
know I mean it's the process the process
yeah because it's it can be chaotic on
it if you've like been shown no yeah I
think somebody was kind of talked about
in a bit but you can teach anyone the
process of recruitment
it's that yeah yeah no it's getting on
the phone they're being able to talk to
people if you talk with people you can
get taught the process and that's what
that's what they did taught me the
process and that's kind of what I'm
always looking to improve a gas is a
process yes they're able to go from Jake
get on the phones make stuff happen to
you I'll actually there's like a clear
process for all of this I have a real
high chance of having more success if I
do more of this part of the process it
will give me a chance and all that it
went from scattergun approach to this
market doing this market know in every
company in your market who you know the
cliche movers and shakers are what the
kind of skill is within Microsoft that
all the companies look for hmm so it got
to a point where it got to a point after
18 months in I was the hottest thing in
Birmingham was angular and clear like
dotnet developers you're angular sand I
just had one at devs and I'd get them
three or four interviews at three or
four places or in some class yeah
exactly so it went from putting up
options on the board of companies to
putting up options of the board of
candidates
mm-hmm and because and if you work with
them exclusively which you should always
be pushing for if you you know if you're
decent in your market so they're only
working with you and because you you
know get yourself known within the
market you you know you're the person to
come to how did you get to know your
market it was getting on the phone
though they're speaking to kind of
speaking to people
you know if announced to like help you
have the best possible chance of
understanding people what was going on
in their world
it's really not not then because like
three four years ago like there wasn't
this building your brand on LinkedIn
yeah then I don't think so it was very
much a told seven because I'd always try
getting a bit earlier stay a bit later
to speak we candidates mmm speaking to
candidates yeah there's like two that's
how you really got yeah we for hours on
the phone every day what other trends
are in the market who's hiring and
spending a lot of time speaking to
candidates and really finding out what
their what they want whether it's
they're looking now or six months down
the line you know and really understand
them yeah exactly because I think it's a
lot easier when you can bring up a
candidate that you've already spoken to
and say you told me you wanted x y&z
I've just spoke to them are you
interested well I was actually looking
but yeah if you've got that mmm that's
when you know recruitment I guess clicks
yeah okay and so the first so the first
four months you didn't bill nope
do you think about quitting I did a bit
but I was getting jobs in interviews
really show us who you was yeah it was
something there to be like now yeah how
was the type of environment around you
was it like Jake keep doing what you're
doing
yeah high off yeah very support is that
that's key isn't I I think I think now
in only recruitment company we've been a
couple of months you can see people
gonna make it or not
why what do you think what that did what
standard that outreach activity activity
yeah if someone's doing activity like I
said you can teach in the process if
they're not doing the activity chances
of getting the opportunity to yeah but
if they're not giving ourselves enough
opportunity exactly recruitment is a
hard game as it is ya know it's
saturated industry and if you're not
doing the activity then I'd say it's not
for you to be honest and then you did
four deals in your fifth month yeah
ma'am it's good to I be for after that
night we went to we did it was the 10
year anniversary and he took everyone
really okay so what what so then after
that was it like you're building your
confidence things were click ah I think
it's snowboard like peaks and traps me
really yeah like what month to have a
big month to three months banking
have another big month so it's like I've
been learning your craft and like how to
get consistent mmm but yeah peaks and
troughs of agreement yeah like that year
that year
what you doing that yeah did just shy of
100 okay
yeah which opened up a brand new market
yeah I was quite happy with that yeah
I'm in under 24 more first year me okay
cool fair enough so I guess just a quick
one on that so you said there about
opening the new market right yeah how so
let's talk a bit about that just because
obviously there's a process as you said
in the first year for months you didn't
bill but and by the end yeah you had
obviously a good result from scratch a
lot of people ask me mate about how they
can go about that or yeah built the
business development piece and stuff
like that
mm-hm obviously we've spoken about
activity and all these things but I
guess how did you approach it so first
and foremost I wanted to know every
company hiring dotnet developers in
Birmingham mmm over the space of the
year did you get given that patch yeah
they just said to me we want you to open
up done every map cool we looked into it
a few companies there go make it happen
kind of thing but cool so you mapped out
mapped out every company don't know how
to you in that LinkedIn LinkedIn yeah
LinkedIn okay power a linkedin really
don't know what mapped out them or it
mapped out and then got on the phone
spec we candidates it was like first
couple months speaking as many
candidates as passing you went on
candidates first yeah whilst you're
stripping series you know getting the
data ready and then come BD you know
you're already gonna have a few
candidates and then just bring in the
company up and selling in their
candidates is that how you so yeah so if
I if I'm listening right now when I'm
early on then building my market double
down on candidates if you're if you're
ringing up a company and just say hi I'm
I'm Jake and kind of recruit for you
they're gonna yeah exactly but if you
ring them up and say hi I'm Jake I know
you're looking for X and I've got X&Y
yeah it's way more powerful exactly and
that that was that was kind of yeah the
craft that I guess I heard that yeah how
was it challenging at first to like
because I'm assuming you knew [ __ ] all
those people it sounded like their
skillset and yeah I get a bit a like
technology so actually like talking to
candidates
about technology about products how the
building them what are they doing to
overcome challenges for their customers
mmm you've got a bit of a personal yeah
exactly
yeah do you think that helps you then
100% because you ringing up you mean
you're not candidate so you're not just
you're asking them what trends lead
looking in the market what are they
interested in
ah I've not heard that before then go
and speak to someone else about that
yeah it just makes you stand out from
the crowd don't it mmm I think also I
can imagine
obviously as we know it's a particularly
tech it's a very saturated market I
think if I'm I'll just feel like fun
room and the tech more can I get hold of
a dot some in whatever developer hmm I'm
not a more good definite places person
is you got this concern and it's like
quite it can be quite transactional
because you know you go out quick far
I'm fast I mean in about after about
just over a year in it got to a point
where I knew that all the other
companies like net and angular so
they're now just going ahead on dotnet
and angular people doozies yeah but do
these people in the tech market like to
pick up the phone no no does anyone ah
classic calling the desk really yeah
yeah obviously not many of them like
they bought call them at the - get the
mobile number speed them after work
really yeah so he's always that what's
the spiel that make because that's like
just immediate saw I don't reckon some
people willing to do that some people
that's thing it wasn't everyone call
them at the desk
you know call them and asking is sending
out loads of emails what you want to do
is if you call them at the - you know
obviously apologize they're gonna get
called at the desk these people happen
it no get it before I apologize and just
get a time to speak with them in the
evenings but what did you say why do
what okay
Jake may I'm at work what that's
absolutely fine but what's that what's
the goal for you - why should I give you
time off to work you know I mean how do
you leverage it to be like this is why
she speaks me off to work and you're how
I'd always say it was I'm keen to
understand your career drivers okay and
then if I have an opportunity that would
match up with your career drivers would
you be interested in that oh yeah right
watch you move on um but I'll call you
at 6 o'clock yeah so there are seven
rather than shoving a job done yeah you
never you never
head on if you had to look someone at
work which I don't do now to be fair
this is the only one I'm pushing on it
bit is because one I never really did it
mmm - and I was with a business last
night that have just started to
implement headhunting in there
yeah of sales activity so they've
decided that they're going to two hours
a day an hour hour slots they're gonna
everyone's gonna be head hunting yeah
and now though because the LinkedIn is
you know you can cost sending someone a
message on LinkedIn you know you're
right I guess it is resourcing to get
them on the phone at a bad time to speak
so you get someone at where you call
them on the mobile even at work because
there's plenty tools out there now to
get someone's mobile number see how this
last one has no secrets and this
conversation last night like every must
know how like how that seeing people get
pissed off and you like how having a
lesser number how do how have you got my
personal number will happen there I'm
happy to say to that yeah if I can get
know your number I just think of the
time I can get you you know what I take
out you saying it's like look you need
to get opportunity to speak to people in
there a bit more have a bit more free
time open to discuss and then it as you
said it's well look I've got a job to
shove down your throat but are you uh
what are you drivers this is why we had
for me to understand because what are
your what are your kind of three most
important things about your career your
time off setting new skills you want to
learn closer to home working from home
and then you know you can build up a
picture of what someone is looking for
and might move for yeah so in three six
month time you get a client that's
offering that you can ring them up and
be like I've got this oh you know what
they yeah that's perfect yeah so that so
you really start to get good at that
yeah that was that was kind of yeah key
for me really and then and then and then
that that then allows you to then I put
up doors on clients because you then
have people to spec out and
yes exactly that you would you get the
candidates spec them out and then build
up relationships like that and then you
want to you know a year 18 months of
that people are coming to you then mmm
just saw what you found
yeah I found that in the markets that I
built give it 18 months to two years
yeah a year to two years and things
start coming to you and that's when
you're gonna I think a big part of that
though is like I mean people are gonna
come to you if you're a [ __ ] recruit
that are there know like how did you
maintain like why do you think people
came back to you besides also being a
great headhunter again a bit cheesy but
just be nice really like being what does
that mean that being nice like so all of
my well I'm the best kinda took place
and work with the clients like I'd
consider them friends now really yeah
have a laugh and a joke with them talk
about the family life what they did it
get to the weekend because you're
speaking with people and people you know
outside of work they're gonna have a
live so if you can just connect with
them on a different level over then have
you got a job for me or Gina blonde a
new job and it sounds so basic but you'd
be surprised other people don't exactly
make like you look on like you see on
LinkedIn like it's people bashing
recruiters and that if you're that type
of person
yeah it might get you a few quick wins
but you're not gonna build up a
sustainable market doing that because
word gets about that happened do you
sort was this lot quite instinctive that
few to approach were that way or is that
just sort of who you are or like I guess
a bit Who I am always but where did you
start noticing that really help shade
you know I mean like cuz I'm sure it got
to a point where he was like
intentionally making sure that you tried
to connect with these people and build
real relationships and stuff or I
noticed it just over my recruitment
career I know the best clients have I've
got on board have come from being like
friends with a developer and they've
like they've basically championed you in
some and the hiring hiring manager mmm
there that's I think how you like the
best relationships I've so then and then
eight months before we left to America
where this American thing come from so I
think the company is way to expand so I
was I was there
so join November I did a full full year
and then it was cute the end of q1 of
the following issue and a key one I
think 2017 I think and I just had a bad
accident snap my leg you know naturally
yeah yeah badly how erase me while used
to race motorbikes
really yeah and just race mobile yeah it
just sounds extremely dangerous yeah
there you go that's why I've got long
yeah that that put me out for like a
month I was off work for a month really
unfair yeah
there the company energized looked after
me that's cross and I remember coming
back from the hospital driving back from
the hush stuff being a hustling for four
days and closed a deal on the drive back
so I thought yeah yeah because I wanted
to make sure I got paid so I used
closing that deal to make sure I got my
full pay because obviously like year in
the day after no I mean so you scratched
you up there but little scratch yours
okay so him and then it was after that
and I noticed I noticed from market
because I was out my market for a month
mmm I just notice everything slowed down
and then they announced they're going to
open America who energize yeah yeah and
then they asked me yeah and they asked
me again a bit like maybe and then they
asked me again and I was just like yeah
[ __ ] it may as well got nothing to lose
20 how did you approach it so we start I
didn't about we're starting about June
and it was it was hardcore for six
months like to use doing all of it in
the UK doing American okay American
Alice who's working 12 to like half nine
how's that you know what at the first at
first I was a bit onshore but then after
a couple months in it was sweet me got
used to it yeah because you'd wake up
wake up at 10:00 go to the gym go to
work and by the time you finish it or
you makes a half court in the pub have
to worry about like you have to worry
about getting home because you gotta be
starting start work at 7:00 again itself
as a yeah so I hate it at first but then
it got pretty sweet and you did that for
six months solid
did that until I did that for about four
months and Waldo how did you identify
the market we just did I just did what I
do best
tap tap New York and because New York
was closer to the UK because of the time
that's why you chose yeah yeah but what
was the market there the same
in Birmingham I started net yeah and
then as time progressed it got to kind
of anything and everything really
anything yeah which is sounds
interesting
yeah that sounds hard work let's break
that down a bit then so forth so you
worked in Manchester yeah four months
solidly yep
build it trying to build up obviously a
sort of American client yeah yeah
McCrimmon desk before you went over yeah
yeah I mean how did you approach that
obviously yeah how the healthy approach
that because we see America is a big
place right so we started off doing New
York there was a few of us doing it one
girl did digital marketing and me over
mate we were all really good mate so I
could help sit and to use all quite good
mates and all the intention the plan was
to go to man yeah yeah okay that's cool
and then so we just mean a guy who
actually work with now we was we just
worked together closely helping each
other open up accounts I think I did
donate he sided with Java and then it
just got to a point where were just like
whatever why was it against uncursed
like was the BD was a bit more BD
focused really why is that I don't
really know we just wait support some
jobs yeah yeah some jobs really how how
was it the obviously the Mancunian just
alright same as anybody in it like got
you got knock on enough doors to break
because that's obviously obviously got
told to you know quietly go away several
times but but I I'm always interested
like cuz I think it'd be an easy
assumption to make please like I like
would they take I don't know like UK
recruiter I know it happens a lot now
you carry you blah blah
but how was it [ __ ] well always fought
because I'm from Manchester where I was
Australian the Queen's English yeah you
don't speak like you know you do down
south it's a bit more I guess you know
northern so people didn't think you're
from England when you say for me like
what for always got mistaken for being
Australian how a lot of people say and a
lot of people have said that people in
America a lot more easier to get hold of
or when you
speaks them a lot more excellent
conversation I didn't think that one is
doin Donette Birmingham but now doing
contracts London yeah really
like yeah you could you could they would
give you the time of day you'd get them
on the phone but then you just won't
hear from them for really you just want
to hear from them yeah I just wanted to
know that would that happened quite a
lot in like a year a year there is you
drink you'd crack open a big account on
how to like a sick be décor with like
the head of tylenol CTO and she's don't
hear from them again really and it's
that's something I have you know heard
multiple times of different people yeah
I think it's just because the scared of
saying you like no yeah they'd rather
not speak to you than say I know we're
not gonna work with you and what what
and then any what was your experience in
life saying you was a real Korea because
a lot of people say like the perception
is totally different over there yeah I
think well when we went over in the
market it was it was we didn't know much
about it soon as I kind of got on the
phones and then you realize we realized
straightaway internal recruitment was
just massive over there yeah going from
yeah corporate recruitment in there yeah
yeah going from doing my little small
market in Birmingham where all the dealt
with CTO is so having to deal with in
internal recruitment it was not a
challenge we're just changing yeah
exactly and you know and then if you go
behind the backs and go to a hiring
manager may soon yeah they don't like it
and like coming back here realize that
as well yeah so how how did you have to
add that to that then what was some we
started I started targeting kind of
startups series a be for the person yeah
right okay yeah places where I kind of
did the deals with companies that had
funding but it hadn't been announced
okay so you'd kind of just been the
right place the right time how did you
identify those would you like reading
relevant being kind of been all over
kind of startup websites i bill in la
estrella
and then it's like you want to run your
BD and you don't sometimes they're not
going to have jobs but you still want to
speak to them get on the radar so it was
more like after when we actually went to
America when was based in LA and
a lot of stops it was just more getting
my name out there and knowing that when
the time is right I can go to Jake yeah
so when he got the investment
I was already in there with them I think
that my son he said yeah did you have to
did you do any deals before you went
over yeah we did one I remember being at
the race the Chester races for like
really an incentive and losing the
incentive in you unbilled well no I did
built from dark very good give me that
just like a courtly finger so you did we
did one in like within the first three
months so I was just like massive big
fear American and here we go American
market yeah be king be king of LA kind
of thing because what was the was that
was a typical deal value over there
minimum 20k so if you're so may that is
mental so when so we terms it typically
20 to 35 obviously you know you can get
35 so remember when the first time we
pitched 35 percent we got laughed at and
Italy yeah typically yeah my average
terms are like 25 percent and minimum
minimum salary for like mid to see need
everyone's okay so like you talk in
senior depth like 7 to 10 years
experience in LA in San Fran like 150 so
how does that compare to UK now lots in
the market like uh Bostick good senior
dev so a good senior from good react dev
in London 70 80 K okay in in satire and
then typical took typical terms that
you'd agree 25% UK is 15 to 20 in it
yeah man mmm so Paul that's a big reason
we've got no companies because it's a
bigger decision you tend to yeah they
won't use recruiters for like junior
candidates
okay the wound and it's a much slower
process it was like six week sales
cycles and it is it's they want to make
they have to meet everyone in the
business about some loved it I've heard
that quite a lot yeah interview process
it was that first thing I remember there
were six stages shut up yeah six days
six stages that's long but you're
chasing it aren't you you're doing every
you can tell her yeah but sure like I
surely like the getting the money's
worth true that's Italy but kind of that
experience that me Oh
top-notch but you know I mean that
candidate to do six stages
you just got to manage the candidates
expectation if there's if there's a
reason why there's another stage you
have to keep that kind of interested in
the position the court explains them why
there's another stage and if they want
the role they'll go for it if there's
another stage and they won't do it
they're not gonna be that interested if
you got them enough or they might not
even take it first so completed America
mmmph we go over there
yeah I'd live the dream for a bit live
the dream for a bit so where did you
move to went to Santa Monica LA okay I'm
was it was it was the visa process like
it was that difficult it was at a time
when the the American was just getting
to you this was like two years ago
mmm so it was they wanted it was easy to
be honest easier yeah yeah so he just
died applied did some forms and went
down to the Embassy for a meeting and
they were just like yeah I've heard it's
now it's a lot of difficult more
difficult because all the companies that
have saturated the market in the UK in
the past couple years of set up offices
in America every company now that you
say you have opening up or got an office
in America
yeah it's just the next Stephanie did
all of Asia Australia like Singapore all
that and just next big steps America and
you move there on your own with your
mates yeah moved there with the girl he
was doing digital Martin Louis close
friend of mine and she's come back now
as well she does internal that am how
how much of a help was that it was it
was good nobody care about each of his
backs but we also live together so it
was just like safe we both had a bad day
was you know that it would have been
tougher poor because so in the first
year we did a deal before we went and
then ending bill fire eight nine months
when you got there when I got there so
it was it was tough man like I was I
savings how do you mean like what did
you have an office yeah we had an
officer who is based in like a Regis
then we move to we work but and we lived
like five minute walk from the office
Susan which was sick you're not going in
for lunch every day just chill out for a
bit
bought hey
mom yeah Mayo stuff like so when they're
made loads of meats and everything
brings my savings and they're not ugly
after a while like all you mates are
going on trips to like some Fran look
like well LA like San Diego Vegas and
it's just like we can't I can't go I
can't afford it I'm not living his life
as now it wasn't and hence why I'm back
right okay why was it so tough because I
like meant mentally really yeah cuz you
can't you can't if you don't got money
you can't go out and party Canyon why
don't you think you build ain't nine
months of like you know I mean what
challenge that think it was probably
like going after anything and everything
but like I said like I said before I was
having like eight to ten in it we used
every month possibly four or five jobs
it was just like that's why that's why I
think it carried on going because I just
know it's gonna happen like I've been
blow you was getting interviews yeah
getting words what what was was what
typically was ended up making those full
free
was there a common thing or not really
are they'd always be some [ __ ] yeah
yeah
always something like one before before
I left it was like everyone wanted it
wanted the guy and then it was just like
one of the board members was just like
no no what did you learn for that period
make because that muscle one knots you
definitely mentally tough until you miss
now you moved their footlocker
better lock you like a whole life on
hold don't you fly a couple years ago
go try at least I was single 26 yeah
someone asked me to go set up an office
in LA exactly I mean you could not
building like when I decided to come
home a couple of deals went in so it was
kind of like I already I was going to me
what do you learn though would you learn
anything more about you setting myself
and my way by being till I like being
able to manage your own like mental
stability
I guess talk to me because it's never
nice not billing it's never nice not
blanking for a month may imagine that I
ain't no monster
yeah well that's thing like proven Billa
yeah they're opened up new markets
already build before we went over to
America don't get me wrong like we had a
couple of offers that just didn't close
or did close and then they got offered
by eBay 50k more and you're gonna
they're gonna do that like the big plays
over there would just can't refer you're
so how did you get better at managing
your mental pitha reading kind of read a
lot of books like meditating stuff like
that and it got it got to a point where
I'd go to the gym but not to like when
you're out early Tony's you go to trim
tonight look good for like you look good
yeah exactly and like look good in the
holiday when you go away with the boys
for all the girls but I'd be from yeah
exactly
yeah but now it's just going to the gym
for like my own mental health like me
like release of endorphins like if I'm
having a [ __ ] day and I go to the gym at
lunch
I feel like so much better and if I'm
not going it is also linked man yeah
exactly and that was that year because I
thought work wasn't going so well I had
to find ways of getting it frustrating
yeah and not become depressed basically
yeah and yeah that sort of stuff would
you read them just like self-help books
I only Robin yeah like the growth
mindset book that kinda stuff and you
know how do you think that just because
my the reason why I'm digging here just
because again a real common thing is
people ask me about sort of Hisham how
come I'm having a [ __ ] patch I like try
and get people to talk about how they
caught a bit more resilience and stuff
like that so you've got look after
yourself man eating healthy like going
to the gym right it does her even for 20
minutes man I'm not one of them like
boys that go to the gym for like two
hours 20 minutes like Timmy by ride like
10 seconds and gone and you're feeling
great yeah I'm like reading and
listening to podcasts I listen past 18
months coffee I listen to a lot of
podcasts so much good stuff
exactly and it's just instead of like
there's obviously times when you listen
to music but just a lot of a lot of the
things you hear of people resonates
mm-hmm and then it's it's kind of Saints
yourself well that's not just me
everyone else has that problem or
everyone else thinks like that hmm and
it just helps you through the day the
day you know the peaks and troughs of
recruitment in it and a lot of a lot of
peaks but also a lot of Charles had
demanded meditation how you might detect
now ah yeah yeah meditates get sleep
every night
really yeah it definitely helps me nice
yeah what's the how has that helped you
mmm if there's a lot of things on your
mind because sometimes you go into bed
and you magistration it's a switch off
in it your finger touching recruitment
you think yeah so I'm very very much
recruiter I can smash the phones all day
but obviously four or five years in it
can it can be it can get tough so you
know if you on a Monday morning or you
don't really smash president anyway but
like saying afternoon he's smashing the
phones and it gets to four o'clock iam
not a good you know conversation with
decision maker should go take go go for
a wonderful five minutes maybe that's
what's really good about oak well it's
very autonomous so you can just go for a
wall go to the shops have a 10-minute
break outside meditation definitely
helped me a more equipment and just
helped me and and helps me in in life
I've definitely slats over the since I
start my own business that's definitely
the challenge of mine but I definitely
in when I was in and recruitment I think
for me one of my challenges earlier on
was like really I was very prone to
getting emotionally attached to like oh
yeah people you already spent the
Commissioner yeah like so it just
enabled me to have that that tool in my
pocket where I was able to take a step
back hmm
that's that's what I mean yeah that's
what meditation can really help you with
instead of like just diving straight
into a situation or a response or
whatever you get better at sort of
taking a moment to be like well let me
just take a [ __ ] breath here for a
second and take a second before I react
or whatever you know I mean yeah you
kind of like train your mind to be able
to handle bad situations so yeah you
know say if you bunk for a month when
you've got a deal and the deal goes down
mentally that computer phone yeah yeah
whereas if you're like you know are you
know what Jake my always telling sup you
know you could recruit you this before
spective enough yeah you come through
this before you know you're dealing with
people that we are dealing with people
that can change them a it's not like
we're selling a product that's x y&z you
know they can easily change the mind mmm
or that you think your rock star
candidate
no [ __ ] up the interview because he
said something stupid or something and
you like you said I already spent the
commission
you can't let after being in recruitment
so long you kind of teach yourself free
like meditation things like that not so
that it gets you is mekong it you can't
get too high on your higher than your
kong exactly it's trying to abstain get
high on your own supply for me two
months yeah too much nothing as a as
recruitment scott has been here longer
though i like to see like the juniors
more like when they do deals and stuff i
that initial bull is like i remember
they're doing them for deals in that
first month for me it went off in that
office my team my team it was like
there's five of us in the team and we
were the top billing team that quarter
so it's like this is my first proper
quarter like in a recruitment office we
were the top billing to you though we
thought we were big man then i'm sure we
build blank team three say just to wrap
up the american experience
yeah yeah so and i mean yeah what was
your gonna say I was gonna say like the
biggest thing for me when I was out
there that help me get the clients that
we didn't know anywhere was like
networking me
go into networking event something that
welcome yeah go into networking I went
to as many as possible
was your boys unlike the meetup happened
yeah like the Eventbrite I think it is
yeah and there's loads in London but
there was in LA there was a few dad and
that's where you know the Crites that we
did Bill into I met from there and I
even met some of the clients were placed
in there and then and what was the
approach at these sort of events just a
pinch
I'd go up a speech everyone really tell
me what you do what they doing what
challenges are facing what do they want
to achieve straighten them yeah a lot of
a lot of times I'd find myself a lot of
like junior devs coming up to me and
asking them because in America to get a
job in development you've got to be
proven they don't hire juniors to train
up really yeah they'd they just hire
senior devs she like to become a dev
you've got to be proven work getting
what job in a start-up have a good
github things like that so I'd have a
lot of junior devs
coming back up so you gotta you gotta
give back even though come work with him
I still giving the time of day so I
become you know follow them on Instagram
talk to them and stuff like that you
gotta you know give back I think you
know give a magnificant a jake would be
follow on instagram there you go we're
just like yes in the back of your mind
it is just like you know if if a couple
years online we're gonna bill maybe bill
with your kind of thing boy it can't be
your only month no mindset ya know like
it sounds a bit cheesy but we're
changing people's lives aren't we yeah I
mean if we can give that advice help
someone change our lives and do what
they want to do I'm all for it yeah I
think now I think that's a good point
you said there because I think a
Fivefinger Leon again and my sort of
recruitment career and you're being
taken seize networking events and it's
like how many business cards can I get
wait for me and then when I realize well
actually no that is definitely not how
you should approach it yeah and the
reason why reason the reason why from
what in my opinion experience is like
you end up putting too much pressure on
yourself now the first the first hour I
go and speak to as many people as a card
is introduced yeah so in the next hour
you know who to have good conversations
with and who's gonna you know who can
you influence and the interesting people
that are in your your kind of area being
at the networking events is probably 80%
of the people you know irrelevant to
what you're doing and what you're trying
to achieve but you said like you know
I'm in chat with them and stuff like
that yeah and now that made sense and
then and then would you and then what
was the approach after these events was
that you were following up yes then in
touch yeah like I said it was never
obviously want to see if the hiring but
it's not every conversation are you
hiring yet you're hiring yet you're
hiring yet it'll be a case of you know
what they do you know what they're
trying to achieve yeah are you read this
article are that's perfect for them have
you seen this
yeah ah no open conversation uh yeah I
have what was your thoughts on it again
open staging and really bring them yeah
it's just offering more than just have
you got any jobs yeah have you ever
hotel in the events I haven't yet
personally to be honest so that's that's
that makes money real quick for Tetra
critters but it's something we're
working on mmm
we've had a big part of my kind of bday
this year is it's kind of find out
exactly why events are because you can
you put event on but then
the CTO is that I'm kind of networking
we are they gonna go have they got the
time of day to go to a networking event
maybe mmm-hmm yeah when you're speaking
with them have they actually mmm so
you've got to make it relevant like what
are they interested in yeah for sure
so I've got kind of a you know a
spreadsheet no a list now of kind of
what all my network are interested in
yeah and it's just it's just for its
yeah you got a better mind kind of when
the time is right mmm to wrap up America
than me yeah now thanks rather nothing
nothing that's really useful for people
and actually just quickly on that how
did you make mates over there so did you
do anything for all Americans or chumps
like all guys like our age like American
jocks like the LA people grade-a chumps
if you don't like them they just English
guys just different viewpoints yeah most
about like most amazing over English
your careers I was quite lucky like
there's a company called console record
them like yeah like nice group of guys
and like they could tell that like me
and like the legacy of a girl were just
like moving to this brand-new country
we're on our own and there was only
three of us in the office so it's not
like we went away probably so yeah it
wasn't like there was loads of us in the
office where you find like the
recruitment companies out there like
stay in that like the friendship circles
yeah so we we met like multiple like
recruitment company circles our mates
yeah so yeah but like everyone everyone
is in the same position so everyone's
everyone's friendly I think that's a
good point because I think yeah if you
know if you're going to America or
thinking about it like definitely reach
out to other recruit you know they're
from the UK where verse and then another
one as well I can't remember company
name but but again all this group of
guys that just like everyone knows what
position what am what should if I'm a
real crew right now got numbers
experience yeah I'm getting absolutely
peppered by ret to wrecks well yeah
I bought a send that gone I think you
should America blah blah blah
just to find the lies out and wrap that
up mate what what should that recruit a
listener might now be fingers they say I
could be considering about two ways in
it if you're in a company and being that
person that's setting it up for them
make sure you've got some clients before
you go okay
so build up before you get
go and be like me and Blackmore you go
yeah definitely no more about and then
what other things everything if you're
like I said client base pick a good
location you got to be prepared like we
went to LA it was so expensive yes take
take some savings it's a big move as
well like have you lived away before mm
can you can you cope are you it
something bad but are you good at just
going making friends in a random place
and then if you're someone on the other
side of it where you get in a lot of
recruiters Peston yeah I would do you
research in every company you know and
speak to some people there I'm probably
try and speak to people that have done
it yeah and to speak people that yeah
you know messaging me if you guys want
if you're getting them chats I'm always
happy to kind of you know share the pros
and cons mm look in the companies one of
my friends from here just went like went
like last couple months ago to New York
to it because he had an American beard
mmm like look where you want to live as
well yeah actually try and get to spend
some time yeah but before maybe yes see
if they'll fly you out there as well is
if a company's keen on yeah you know
they they're happy to invest 10 Kania in
your visa and getting you out that see
the office if you're a decent biller
because one needs to be made out there
yeah you'd like to think they'd spent
they'd pay four six seven eight hundred
exams like to go check in on me feel of
the vibe make sure if you do go there
you know make sure they kind of put you
up for like two weeks a month in a hotel
because you know fine in the place is
stressful yeah especially you just moved
in a new place and might not have many
friends but most of the compass that
feel out there now because it's been
like two three years on it everyone on
that the American Journey the set up you
know you're not going to be their first
person to go so yeah
you should have you know you should look
at to see how many people they've taken
over there because then they'll have
like a decent process and to make sure
you feel comfortable yeah for sure got
some really good advice mate so back to
back home back home and money back to
Manny
and so been here for nearly a year yeah
now mm-hmm and you are now a contract
yeah recruiter yeah
when tech contracts recruit a London bit
different very different
what's been going on like how this beam
is been back to square one building your
market I'm basically gone to back but to
being kind of like a junior recruiter in
a new market you've got to go back to
principles because I saw I saw big
contract pillars that make decent money
and the first few years are tough but
then it gets easier and I was always
just looking at them like I'm better
than you at this game but my process is
nailed on I feel like I'm better
candidates and clients so it's been hard
because it's mostly BD you know come
from had one in which is all client or
candidate where it's a mostly BD work
it's what's been the biggest challenge
so far biggest challenge is London is
just probably like having conversation
with these people but actually getting
on having cook because you BD a company
ninety percent of them will have either
don't use recruiters I'll have an
internal team so there's probably only
ten percent of companies are tortilla
and out of them ten percent companies
say if it's ten of them none of them
weren't even hire contractors so just
like the amount of companies and
especially the changes of my ir35 and
briggs it may it's just tough finding
the people that's where you've got to
have deeper meaningful conversations
with your clients other than just have
you got a job
mmm that's where I kind of been
interested in tech comes in and having
having your list of like 100 candidates
and clients you can just have a chat
wave and see what's happening in the
market because you know they're gonna
know what what projects are happening
they're gonna know who's building an MVP
and kind of ready to take out to market
so so how have you approached it then on
what's been the process that's crap yeah
starting from scratch but actually from
scratch starting from scratch yeah yeah
we had a few key clients but yes
starting from scratch and a big a big
thing for me is kind of a few things
data you know being Pratt's you know you
don't want to be spending nine seven ten
thirty sorting you know you're out you
know you need to be perhaps for you you
know like your core sessions or your
core sessions might not like right I'm
just talking like nine to twelve in like
two to five I'll teach you like are five
what you do and then those and that song
like being proactive in
to splice having conversations with
people trying to really yeah you're
messaging people messaging people
LinkedIn and like I said like get any
data ready and then after a few months
in the market speaking to Candida
speaking to client you become friends of
people mindset so I've got my list now
of like 100 candidates hundred clients
or more kind of more candidates to
clients because a lot more contracts out
there and then what contracts is then
contracts so and just getting your name
out there that's tough but you know the
first year in everyone's market it's
always tough unless you work and walk
into a warm more market but we just
start until I really see the fruits of
our labor now really yeah when the team
when it came in here it was just another
guy and the director and now we were a
team of four with another guy joining
and we went from like two runners out
were like over like 25 now in the space
of a year so and how do you think and
then how have you just go out how have
you got better at I guess it's just I
guess it's been a process as you're
saying but anything to sort of just
people listen in terms of the beat yeah
one thing goes back to it is it's kind
of like reading so I'm reading like
start books like the lean style for
example and kind of come wider than that
I guess a for me to learn but then to
have better conversations good if I if
I'm talking to a startup and I've
noticed they've changed a product and
you can go out some black are you've
iterated the product there I can see
that why have you done that my such a
better conversation that have you got a
contract well has paint so the about 100
over recruit is calling a lot because
even get them on the phone and half the
time they tell you they did out of town
in a meeting
mmm-hmm and saturated market tech
recruitment and that your mom that's mad
it is how have you dealt with like these
barrack roots out there but how many of
them are actually decent yeah no you're
right how many of them are just gonna be
junior recruiters joined a company got
told to do this or how many of them I
got into a company they've got loads of
key accounts that they'll just work on
mmm which will get their you know we're
in the urine and fair enough me I guess
how what is this hole
I are 35 so it's just government
changing but how is it how is it how did
you see it and impact them from what
you've surely impacted me and what way
so I'm when I go meet my candidates now
on clients like so when to meet and last
week took Alma took all my runners out
my contractors out forum for date from
meal lunch at one point everyone run the
table asked me kind of what's happening
buy or 35 there's there's six people or
five including the dev manager so six
every one of them at one point because
because it can really shake up the
market and there's a lot of uncertainty
around it companies don't know what to
do
so I'm when does an iron play by April
next year so I'm just like clue myself
up and speaking so an element of people
don't know yeah people don't know what
that means then the decisions and the
city much information out there but the
information is there
you just gotta go find it and gain an
understanding of it so then you can
consult you know that's what we're can
all consultants aren't we yeah if I can
consult with the CFO of how he's going
to save money how I could save him 20 30
grand on a on a project for 6 to 12
months mmm he's gonna give me that time
of day any mmm and especially all the
big banks in the past week I said
they're gonna get rid of all the
contractors really so yeah like the next
six months is gonna be interesting
especially we record it in the contract
market so that's why you need to be how
to preparing for that bro bit of a
cliche but being different is like
having conversations yeah other than
just have you got jobs you know beam
remember all rememberable memorable
memorable memorable yeah that's fair
enough man I think that's instead of
just bringing them up nice and you got
jobs like what are you offering if you
just ringing up and ask him for a job
because these I plan to be doing
contract London now for the next like
four or five years really yeah yeah
exactly that's that's my plan so you
know I'm gonna be dealing with these
people for yeah I can imagine as well
I've been around like the uncertain
staff the stuff autumn you don't have
control of it's like I just feel like
I'd be a good thing to be positive about
and view it from a positive positive way
and see what the challenge
yeah but if you see them challenges
opportunities then you're gonna stand
you know hadn't shoulders above the rest
I think that that's what the best what
critics would do right though they'll
look for the opportunities they're not
just gonna let that sort of stuff
paralyze them and it's taking a couple
of weeks or thinking of how I'm gonna do
this you know you look at you look at a
challenge and then you reflect upon it
and seeing you know how can i how can i
how can kind of my clients use my
services to get over this challenge you
know more effectively and how can I add
more value than the hundred other
contractors so what's been what's been
there so I'm a pawn recruit right now
thinking about contracts my mates
contract below telling me what about all
the money is getting what what would I
need to know him fully understand now
you're nearly a year in the game of
being there you're gonna be chasing the
job is a lot more hmm you know you're
gonna be because the win for him 80%
sourcing to 20% BD or even 200% sourcing
you know you want to get to position
perm where you're not doing be doing
roles are coming you basically become a
resource so for yourself going to the
opposite end of the spectrum where you
know 9% of your time is you've got a bit
comfortable being there that yeah you've
got you if you can if you I'd say if
you've got it be dig contracting this
for you really you know everyone's
different and everyone's got their own
skills and abilities but yeah if you're
more of a resource ER or if you don't
like getting on the phones or don't like
go into events and speaking with people
it's gonna be tough but yeah if you
companies got some key key accounts and
yeah mmm have you been going to events
in London yeah I'm going for a few a few
how's that been going really well
yeah yeah really well as a couple couple
of key ones we go to like every month
and has that helped you win on clients
or yeah yeah and then with me summer
some of if you've got some big clients
they will probably hold events get
yourself on that invite yeah there'll be
people there that you don't know invited
my Polly with the internal rec which if
you deliver and you should be just kind
of come to this event I can I can seem
to add value to our company so one of my
clients always does like that HR is
really big
and they always put in like hit our
events and that's gonna help our help
Hampton fair enough hmm
if he was a fuse to communicate to Jake
early on your recruitment career
hmm what do you say then what you know
now it's a tough one was just like keep
I it like the times when like the
troughs for example yeah when you go
into three months like not billing just
like keep I it it's like there'd be
times where they like I remember once
like looking at other jobs like looking
at things away from recruitment is this
for me
kind of thing that had that probably
conversation kind of every couple of
months in Marinette but then it's you
know you just got remember the good
times
mmm-hmm you know you got you got
remember like this this games taking me
taking me to LA and stuff like that and
I don't think a company would have asked
me to go to LA if you know you're not a
half-decent recruiter yeah what helped
you keep at it do you think setting
goals setting goals setting goals is
massive mate not like yearly goals but
like weekly monthly goals so I start
this year I really want to go to Brazil
I'm really really ready to go to Brazil
and it was like right I need to get he's
starting contract needs to get x-metal
runner so by this time I will have fun
so you really broke it down really broke
it down got you've got to you've got to
if you don't then you don't know yeah
exactly and those then like weeks gave
me so much more then like weeks in a few
months gave me so much motivation when I
was starting up a market where you do
need you need to be on the phones all
day every day you might not pull the job
for like a month two months because it's
just so difficult to find jobs so you
need that extra to get up in the morning
so if you're just waking up and I've
gotta go you know gotta go selfish just
smashed out the phone so lines of emails
I'll be somewhere easy you're getting up
in the morning saying right I'm gonna
smash today because I'm going Brazil in
a couple of months it's it's a lot it's
a lot easier mentally to ya plan and
prepare and like I said you know I've
got goals for like two three years and
things like that yeah and no I guess
from my experience I know if I kind of
keep I and with a strategy that we use
in in terms of bringing new clients on
board and and things like that that we
will get there and you kind of
achieve those goals not a lot that makes
to have goals and those goals make sure
you really break down no more activity
and things needs to be doing a weekly
monthly basis that is gonna help you get
there so goals and then nailing down
your process months I think like I said
before like anyone can be taught this
process in recruitment I feel like every
like you could literally write like a
book of what to do every single call
every single step of the way and as you
you know your first year but even if you
don't do big numbers just hone that
craft master oh yeah just muster
basically going back to school and
there'll be you know most companies will
have you know decent builders they might
even have a training partner or you know
the directors you know hopefully you're
in a company where you directors give
you that time of day mm-hm luckily every
company I've been but you know you hear
some some stories yeah so yeah like
goal-setting and process yeah and I nail
that down kind of all the peaks and
troughs through recruitment will take
care of themself if you kind of you know
have that have those mmm I came out as
we finish them me mm-hmm
what how do you how do you see this
whole recruitment world planning out
mate from your purchase as in like yeah
like everyone says what cream has change
in and oh yeah I mean how do you see it
changing and you're so I know it's when
I went to America that internal was
massive coming back I've noticed it
massive I know a lot of my friends going
internal someone told me this happened
about 10-15 years ago though like the
early noughties yeah so I think it will
be a cycle it's you know companies
realizing the spending a lot of money on
recruitment and they could have a couple
of internal people and save the money
that's all it is unfortunately though
cheering of not good recruiters will
make them you know take up a partner I
don't get to a position where I can you
can partner with these companies and
take a take away that aspect of the
headache and do it for you know I guess
like retain recruitment you need to be
offering your clients more than just are
you've got job I'll fill it you need to
kind of help them grow the business with
their brand new solve the real
like real rule actually a be a business
partner yeah and you see real crews are
gonna throw more that way hundred
percent yeah otherwise you're just gonna
be one of them one of them kind of
recruiters that just switches jobs every
three six months or an internal
recruiter that just kind of sits there
for three six months and you know ruin
the breakdown and the candidate kind of
attractions of company because I've
worked with companies where you working
with internal recruiters and for some
reason through lack of training and
things like that the process is not
nailed down and candidates then I'm just
like well I interview two weeks ago and
I've not heard back yeah like candidates
do candidates talk in the market yeah I
was researching about every week and I
rang someone and he was like are my
friend told me and I was just like that
I'm not going forward for it and it
could've been a great fit but because
the process wasn't nailed down and it
just you know it could have fat
companies yeah of course tell you get
that mm-hmm
before how do you think it's changing
then I'll throw that one back at you how
do i fingers oh yeah yeah I think
there's a lot of what you said I think
some in a sort of this weird pocket of
like speaking to people at you and then
speak to other businesses and I think
definitely from from what I'm seeing
it's businesses that are willing to take
a risk and try and offer real solutions
to real client problems so if that's put
in five Jake Whitby's on site for four
days a week and often a real talent
solution where you then get involved in
the talent strategy and yeah the
interview process and the candidate
experience and actually really impact
that as well as deliver the jobs I think
that sauce that's exactly kind of you
know strategy I've been talking about
with my directors to be honest yeah so
there's that going on there so there's
the sort of whole embedded on-site
solution where um yeah the same sort of
thing base it's that it's like um you
pay me X per month you get that you know
how much you know how much some of the
companies are charging out for that do I
know how yeah yeah it's kind of very
much I mean you're looking at three six
months contract so I was speaking to
some speaking some exact embedded model
one of the big players ten grand I see a
month ten grand I see ten grand pharisee
yeah
what you think nice expensive expensive
for someone that's not been in
recruitment a while and yeah I guess it
depends got six months experience at
recruiting an agency that like no
offense like it's not work for some
reason or another no training no you're
right I'm charging ten grand a month
it's ridiculous again you gotta fit you
gotta favor again at the same time like
these people trying to solve real
problems it's all gonna be a process how
they really really deliver for their
clients but I think that'll be
interesting how that plays out how
agencies respond at the same to what
what I will say on this point is that a
lot of aging a lot of people saying this
change in blah blah blah that's a lot of
people not changing oh you gotta be God
but you got a trait your products every
now and then you can't but honestly make
like there's a lot of people not didn't
an infant's change well they're the
people just be by the wayside really I
know but it's not yeah if you've got
some massive key accounts where you
billion hundreds of thousands of pounds
you know we got to do is look after you
counts on it yeah you're a company like
well four years in the market yeah you
know you've got some a really good team
and a really nice office in Manchester
you you do need to iterate and kind of
condoms and you know create this market
is very saturated and if you can kind of
create your own little space and your
own little offering yeah there you go
maybe even cracked it so this exciting
to see how that plays out it's gonna be
I think the next break is it one breaks
it's all finished it's gonna be exciting
when I have 50 fires finished but I
think next year we'll see I have me
enforceable happen next year but I think
once ever breaks it calm down will be
the UK I'll just go back to normal and
it'll just be smashing it again mmm so
were you excited about mate before last
question what's gone on in your world
that you wanna shout about my inside
outside finish finish in the air fun no
not again yeah I wouldn't exactly call
saying yeah whence this our parlor in
Rio and satima girlfriend yeah that I'm
here in LA OH
a van that was stopped all that was
alright Rio was sick yeah I definitely
definitely going back there why was it
there it's just like like just seemed
like all the shanty towns like doing all
the touristy parts the beach Copacabana
beach yeah going like to the Christ
Redeemer statue so yeah it was a really
sick trip but obviously like I said like
goal setting I wouldn't have been able
to get there if it didn't set them goals
and gonna have that kind of drive to get
up and get on with my work
um but yeah that's what she's gonna be
moving over here at the next year so the
old main old soldier the Manchester
dream how she loves it to be fair to be
fair that she likes London as well which
is annoying
[Laughter]
last question always ask people mate is
if you could communicate every single
recruiter out there they'd listen and
take on your advice it could be a phrase
or word sentence peaks and troughs Pete
like there's a good time spot there's
something called this good times but
there's the bad times and you know it as
long as the good times outweigh the bad
times like that that's you you enjoy it
yeah and I people in there like getting
into the game it is fun
like if my first few years in recruiting
like when I was energized it was it was
great it was yeah
and now here like it's way because I'm
getting a bit older and I'm seeing how
I'm 27
so I know I say I'm getting older but
there's nothing you see like hey like we
hire juniors and train them up and it's
it's good to see like them like always
going out and like I don't go out as
much anymore
ya know till I have fun and like if you
can talk to people and you're in a good
a good like working environment they
will teach you the process and like I
said like have fun is is is fun to
explain in pleasure man thanks very much
good it